but we're going to begin with that
massive verdict handed down in a lawsuit
against Alex Jones the jury determined
the radio talk show host and conspiracy
theorist must pay nearly one billion
dollars in damages to the families of
Sandy Hook shooting victims Jones
repeatedly called the school massacre a
hoax on the air last year a judge found
him liable of defamation by default
after he failed to produce documents
demanded in the lawsuit and Nikki
Batiste has been following this case for
months we find her at the courthouse in
Waterbury Connecticut where the Judgment
was read yesterday Nikki good morning
Tony good morning while I sat in the
courtroom near several of the San Diego
victims family members as that verdict
was read and they were emotional yet
poised several told me soon after they
were in shock but that this is the
accountability they want Jones to face
after enduring years of harassment from
him and his supporters
in less than 3
-cited the conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones must pay more than 965 million
dollars in compensatory damages for
spreading false claims that the 2012
Sandy Hook school shooting was a hoax I
let my voice be taken away from me
Robbie Parker lost his daughter Emily
Parker testified that a video of him
speaking at his daughter's funeral was
mocked by Jones I'm just proud that
what we were able to accomplish was just
to Simply tell the truth Jones and his
company Free Speech systems were sued by
eight victims families and an FBI agent
who responded to the shooting over
claims the company made Millions
spreading misinformation about the
tragedy Jones and his attorney
maintained that the trial was a sham and
an attack on his first amendment rights
though he was not in court Jones watch
live on his webcast he cheered while the
verdict was read mocking the families
and saying they won't receive any
payments How likely is it that this will
financially ruin or could financially
ruin Alex Jones well one of the things
that Alex Jones tried to do throughout
this case was to hide his assets Jones
company filed for bankruptcy in July but
a forensic Economist in a previous case
estimated that Jones is personally worth
as much as 270 million since this case
will not have a cap on punitive damages
Judge Barbara Ellis will now consider
how much Jones will ultimately have to
pay the fight also continues for Mark
Barton who lost his son Daniel in the
tragedy and after each Victory Daniel's
still dead
and nothing will bring him back
but everything that I do is to protect
others from having to live this pain
the jurors also determined that Jones
should pay the plaintiff's legal and
attorney fees Jones lawyer said he plans
to appeal the decision the radio host
feases a third trial in Texas later this
year over a lawsuit filed by the parents
of another child killed in the shooting
Gail
Nikki Batiste thank you